2024 is going to be an amazing year for
apple and Apple Fans because they are
going to be having 14 different products
that are going to be released and that
might be the most ever released in just
one year now I'm going to be covering
all of them and when they're going to be
released in the year and the first one
might be coming this month and that will
be Apple's amazing and amazingly
expensive Vision Pro now this thing
looks incredible pushing VR and AR Tech
to a quality in a place that has never
even been close to before the crazy ey
tracking and hand tracking is going to
make this such a nice experience that is
much easier than using controllers now I
recently flew to New York and I would
have loved to have that on the airplane
and it's going to have the best displays
ever built into a VR headset it's going
to really improve the quality of what
you see you're going to see way less
pixels and I am super excited to go
ahead and get this thing tried out and I
know that it's going to be the first
product apple is going to release in
2024 and based on this Chinese investor
site they're claiming that it could come
out on January 27th for that event now
of course that could be just in their
Chinese time zone because Friday the
26th makes much more sense for an apple
launch here in the states and the next
product or products that are going to be
release are the brand new airpods 4 and
they could be coming out the same time
as the Vision Pro
now the interesting thing is that we are
getting two sets of airpods 4 since the
airpods 2 are going to finally be
replaced and the more expensive model is
going to get active noise cancellation
which is going to be a first for a nonpr
set of airpods now of course with that
they're going to get transparency mode
which is great they're also going to get
a new case with speakers and tracking
built in to help you find them and I'm
personally very excited for that and the
lower price regular airpods as well now
the next one is the airpods max which
are also supposed to be coming out the
previous ones launched a few years ago
they still have lightning and the
biggest update is going to be USB type-c
we're going to get some new colors but
nothing really major because they are
already are very good now one lineup
that's going to get a massive update are
going to be the new iPads now if you
didn't know 2023 was the first year
since the iPads came out where Apple
didn't not released a new iPad usually
Apple releases multiple iPads sometimes
at once or sprinkled throughout the year
but last year we got nothing and in 2022
we got the 10 CH iPad where it was
finally redesigned we got a refresh iPad
air with a powerful M1 chip inside and
of course iPad Pros with M2 chips now
iPads have had bad sales lately it keeps
declining because the M2 iPad Pros were
such a minor update so the first set of
new iPads are going to be the M3 iPad
Pros which are going to get a much
bigger redesign possibly the biggest one
ever now one big new feature is going to
be ma safe wireless charging right where
that Apple logo is that section is going
to be made out of glass to make that
possible now this should have came out
with the M2 iPad Pros but Apple delayed
it and gave us the very boring stop Gap
update now it will finally happen this
year with details that we have from a
company that actually makes those
magnets we're also looking at getting
dual layer OLED displays which will be
ultra bright and blend the best of mini
LED that we currently have and OLED
technology so this is possibly going to
be the best display that is on the
market at all uh but uh definitely for a
tablet and it's also going to be quite
expensive now with that the magic
keyboard 2 will be released with Max
safe charging support and it's going to
have an aluminum design around the
keyboard area which which is going to
resemble what a Macbook looks like so
it's going to be a lot more premium and
durable now the other side is going to
be silicon that way we can still have
that Mac safe pass through wireless
charging we should also have updated
cameras finally with a landscape layout
as well as a new Apple pencil so we're
going to get multiple different
accessories along with these 14 products
now we got leaked code names for these
new iPads so they should be coming out
very soon likely in March and there are
a bunch of patents that are available
that apple ad so we made a very detailed
video that you guys can check out after
this one the next one is the 12.9 in
iPad Air we know that apple is going to
be releasing new iPad Airs and the most
interesting one is that large size one
we also had two leaks with code names
j53 7 and j53 which are completely
different from the iPad Pro code names
now this is going to be similar to the
10.9 in iPad ear but just a larger one
it's not going to get any crazy new
features just give people the option to
have a large siiz iPad that is more
affordable than the iPad Pros especially
if the pros get a price hike now the M2
Chip is likely going to be in these
iPads upgraded from the M1 and the M3s
will be saved for the pros now there's
also a good chance that these will come
out in springtime at the same time as
the pros since we got no iPads in
2023 now we have another iPad and that
is the iPad Mini externally it's going
to be staying the same as the mini 6
which launched a couple years ago now
2021 uh but it's going to get a much
more powerful chip likely the 3 NM a17
since the mini 6 also got the a15 at the
same time as that chip launched in the
iPhones it's also going to get new
cameras because the current ones are
really outdated we're going to get
better wi-fi because that's also
outdated and there is a chance that we
might also get this in the spring if not
it could come out in September possibly
with an a18 but we will have to see now
for the last iPad we have the iPad 11
the iPad 10 just got that full redesign
so I don't think we're going to get a
very big update probably just an updated
chip because Apple usually Updates this
base version pretty often and now let's
talk about the MacBook airs because they
are getting the M3 chip now externally
it's going to look the same as the 13-in
MacBook a and then of course the 15-in
MacBook a that currently have the M2
chips but the M3 is a lot more powerful
especially in its CPU we saw in
cinebench we had a 45% difference
compared to the M3 14-in MacBook Pro and
then in xcode we had a 23% difference in
performance now of course the airs are
fanless so the difference is going to be
slightly smaller comparing uh both
fanless machines but I will will say
that the M3 chips that we tested well
they use the same amount of power as the
M2 meaning throttling will not be any
worse now with that they're also more
efficient so we are going to get a
little bit better battery life now as
far as Graphics if you look at the unbin
chip we're looking at 45,000 compared to
47,000 in geekbench metal so the
difference there is very slim but of
course we have Ray chasing capabilities
that can also be applied to 3D rendering
that can make a pretty good um
difference there if you care about that
right now you can get those M2 air
MacBooks for killer prices great
discounts I did a six-month review of
the 15-in MacBook a so if you don't
really need a lot more performance well
you can just get a killer dealer right
now and not have to wait for that which
is going to come sometime between maybe
March and June now along with that in
June we are looking at other new Macs
like the Mac Studio now this is going to
be a basic refresh it's going to look
the same but inside we are going to go
to the M3 Max and M3 Ultra chips now the
crazy thing is we just got those
launched in the MacBooks and the M3 Max
can actually match up with an M2 Ultra
in a lot of tests and even beat it out
in certain tests which makes the Mac
Studio kind of irrelevant for a lot of
people because you can pay the same
price but get a full laptop that is
portable at the same time now when we
get the M3 Ultra that is going to be a
massive update for that machine and make
it be very competitive in the Mac lineup
as well as comparing to PCS and the next
product that's going to come out also
around WWDC is the Mac Pro also with an
update right now it is an even more
Niche machine than it was before because
it's just a way more expensive version
of the Mac Studio at the same
performance so for most people people it
does not make sense to buy it now I
really hope Apple would do something to
make it stand out more this year like
the extreme chips that were uh rumored
or the addin cards to give it more
performance that we also had leaks about
uh but knowing Apple they could just say
hey you know what we're not selling a
lot of them anyways we don't really care
and they'll just keep it the same just
put in the M3 Max and the M3 Ultra and
then later in the year we are going to
get new phones starting with the iPhone
16 they update them every year but this
year is going to be a decent update like
we had last year where we got killer
updates we are looking at a new action
button that's coming from the pros as
well as a new capture button for photos
and videos and a redesigned camera setup
that could look a lot different and
instead of using a one-year-old chip in
it like they have been it's going to get
a brand new a18 chip based on new 3
nanometer Tech and of course we have the
iPhone 16 Pros which are expected to get
slightly bigger displays brand new Chips
of course being called the a18 pro this
time being more powerful than the
regular one now the ultrawide camera
should get a massive update this year
going from 12 megapixel to a much better
48 megapixel and then the smaller size
iPhone 16 Pro is going to get the
amazing 5x telephoto that currently you
can only get on the pro Max And as far
as Apple watches this year is going to
be a really big one now for the Apple
watch Ultra we currently don't really
know much at all but personally I hope
that we at least get that space black
color that was rumored last year because
other than that it's probably going to
stay very similar but for the regular
Apple watch the series X or the series
10 it's going to be a major overhaul
it's going to have a brand new design
being thinner and we are going to have a
brand new magnetic band system with new
Health features so your old bands will
not work but the new ones are going to
allow it to have some really cool new uh
Health features new sensors and some new
designs now we have a lot more info
about the Apple Watch series X or 10 you
guys can see that video right over there
definitely check it out go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
this has been Max and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
one